[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
ich zitiere Pontius Pilatus
ich wasche meine Hände in Unschuld
sprich die ältere Dame im Gerichtssaal
und hält ihr cruzifix hoch an andermal
flustet sie sich auf und sagt mit
Verschwörer Miene mit diesem Spielberg
habe ich Kontakt er will meine
Geschichte verfilmen nach vielen vielen
schrecklichen Morden und serienmorgen
von Männern wollten wir endlich mal
wieder füllen bisschen Ausgleich sorgen
hier bei Tatort Deutschland und erzählen
euch heute die Geschichte einer Mörder
in hallo und herzlich willkommen bei
Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer Mirko ich
finde unsere Gewichtung bei den
Geschlechtern die kommt schon hin also
wenn wir mal nur Deutschland nehmen dann
werden laut dem Statistischen Bundesamt
87,5 Prozent der Morde durch Männer
begangen und nur 12,5% von Frauen die
meisten Mörderinnen wiederum töten
Männer im Familienumfeld und zwar häuf
mit Gift als durch pure Gewalt und
spannend sind natürlich auch Daten über
die wenigen serienmörderinnen die es
gibt zum Beispiel wird eine
durchschnittliche Serienmörderin erst
nach sechseinhalb Jahren gefasst der
männliche Serienmörder bereits nach
zweieinhalb Jahren das sind wir Frauen
wollen bisschen cleverer na wenn du das
sagst dann muss das ja wohl stimmen auf
jeden Fall sind es auch bei unserer
heutigen Täterin tatsächlich etwa
sechseinhalb Jahre sie heißt Elfriede
Blauensteiner und sie ging als die
schwarze Witwe in die österreichische
Kriminalgeschichte ein das ist jetzt
nicht so originell wir hatten ja zum
Beispiel auch erst vor kurzem dem Fall
von belgunis die Folge findet ihr unter
die schwarze Witwe hier im Feed also
einfach danach suchen
begann ist die wurde auch so genannt es
gibt übrigens auch eine schwarze Witwe
von Bodenfelde eine schwarze Witwe des
Internets namens and Shepherd oder die
schwarze Witwe shisako okay hier in
Japan falls ich das falsch ausgesprochen
habe tschuldigung da ist der Filmtitel
zu unserem heutigen Fall schon deutlich
markanter die Gottesanbeterin aber Toni
eins ist schon wirklich krass die
schwarze Witwe Elfriede Blauensteiner
suchte ihre Opfer genauso über
Kontaktanzeigen wie belganes ja das
stimmt also der Tipp war ab nimmt keinen
Briefkontakt zu schwarzen Witwen auf
obwohl ich glaube Briefkontakt jetzt
auch nicht mehr so gängig ist Elfriede
Blauensteiner wird am 22 januar 1931 in
Wien geboren sie wächst im südlichen
Stadtteil Favoriten mit fünf
Geschwistern auf der Vater ist im Krieg
gefallen die Verhältnisse sind
bescheiden als junge Frau heiratet
Elfriede einen Mann namens Alfred F sie
bekommen eine Tochter
von dieser Tochter hört man übrigens
viele Jahre in der Öffentlichkeit
überhaupt gar nichts also wirklich
absolut gar nichts wir widmen ihr später
ausführlich das Ende dieser Ausgabe
schon kurz nach der Geburt trennt sich
Alfred von Elfriede und lässt sie mit
dem Kind allein später sagt Elfriede
dass sie von dieser Zeit an Männer
grundsätzlich gehasst habe
ja aber andererseits lebt sie von nun an
immer von Männern von deren Geld genauer
gesagt in keiner unserer Unterlagen
findet sich ein Beruf dieser Dame
überall wird sie immer Witwe genannt und
wenn man so drauf ist wie die blauen
Steine dann ist es auch eine Art von Job
das teuflische das sieht man ihr dabei
nicht an
Elfriede wirkt auf Fotos nett rotblonde
dauergewellte Haare Brille sie lächelt
viel wenn man sie so sieht würde man von
ihr ein gutes Kuchenrezept erwarten
Leute wie sie trifft man sicher auch auf
Busfahrten für Rentner aber Elfriede
Blauensteiner ist nicht zu harmlos wie
sie auf den Fotos wirkt zum ersten Mal
kommt sie im Jahr 1981 mit einem
Todesfall im Berührung weil sie für
dieses Delikt nie verurteilt wird sind
die Informationen darüber eher spärlich
angeblich hilft sie dem Hausmeister
ihrer Wohnanlage einem Mann namens Erwin
Niedermeier sehr aktiv beim Selbstmord
und zwar mit Gift und angeblich hatte
der Mann Schuld auf sich geladen indem
er seiner Ehefrau einen Schädelbruch
zugefügt hatte in der Zeit danach
genauer gesagt 1982 da heiratet Elfriede
wieder und zwar Rudolf Blauensteiner der
arbeitet bei der Staatsbahn ÖBB als
Fahrdienstleiter und so wirklich eine
glückliche Ehe ist das ganze auch nicht
aber dazu gleich mehr bevor wir uns um
Rudolf kümmern müssen wir uns aber
erstmal über Otto reine unterhalten
den betagten Otto Reinel hat Elfriede in
ihrer Nachbarschaft kennengelernt und zu
ihrem Ziehvater ernannt Kosename fadili
der Kreis leidet an Diabetes und als er
1986 so gut wie bettlägerig wird nehmen
ihn die blauen Steine zu häuslichen
Pflege in der Wohnung auf irgendwann hat
der arme Mann seine Ausscheidungen nicht
mehr im Griff und geht seinen Gastgebern
auf die Nerven
er hat mir die Wohnung verdrängt sagt
die blauen Steiner später zu ihrer
Rechtfertigung
Elfriede ist mittlerweile routiniert im
Umgang mit dem Diabetes Medikament
durch stetige Überdosierung bringt sie
den alten Mann schließlich um reine ist
permanent unterzuckert die Organe
versagen am Ende
später im Prozess wird sie sagen ich
habe ihn von seinen Leiden befreit
aber 1986 fällt nach dem Tod des
Diabeteskranken Rentners erstmal
niemandem etwas auf Elfriede hatte wenn
man so will ein Erfolgserlebnis und
traut sich jetzt ihre unglückliche
zweite Ehe zu beenden außerdem gibt es
mittlerweile ein Laster eine Sucht die
ihr ganzes Leben beherrscht Elfriede
Blauensteiner ist Dauergast im Casinos
sie ist spielsüchtig Elfriede
verabreicht ihrem Mann Rudolf
Blauensteiner jetzt immer wieder das
Medikament das hat sich ja schon als
tötungsgift bewährt bei ihrem Vati sie
mischt das Medikament mal im Café mal in
einer Limonade unter und im Sommer 1992
da fällt der unglückliche Kerl ins Koma
ohne zu begreifen was eigentlich los war
und so stirbt Rudolf Blauensteiner am 10
August 1992
die trauernde Witwe lässt ihren Rudi
vorsorglich einäschern seine Urne wird
im Grab von Otto Reindl beigesetzt der
rudi hat seinen Tod verdient kommentiert
sie den Mord später aber zunächst
bemerkt niemand etwas Elfriede beseitigt
Leute von denen sie genug hat und
profitiert möglichst noch von deren
Schenkungen und Testamenten kaum ist
Rudi unter der Erde da sucht sich die
blauen Steine ihr nächstes Opfer diesmal
aber eine Frau
Franziska Köberl ist 84 Jahre alt und
eine Nachbarin von Elfriede betagt und
wohlhabend als Körpers Mann stirbt zieht
die alte Dame zu ihrer netten Freundin
Elfriede als Zeichen guten Willens im
gemeinsamen Haushalt überschreibt sie
ihr die gut gefüllten Sparbücher und
berücksichtigt sie in ihrem Testament
wieder verabreicht Elfriede heimlich
eu-cohn das den Blutzucker senkt ja aber
die alte Lady die nachschauen Süßes und
hebt damit die Wirkung des Medikaments
auf aus Versehen sozusagen also kann
Süßkram auch Leben retten ja aber in
diesem Fall nur eine kleine Weile
denn Elfriede erhöht die Dosis und
erreicht wenig später ihr Ziel
Franziska Köberl stirbt am 15 dezember
Elfriede kassiert das gesamte Erbe und
die Sparbücher und kann eine Weile
wieder Geld im Casino verprassen aber
lange wird es nicht halten
bisher hat der Zufall Elfriede ihre
Opfer zugeführt und vielleicht auch ihre
scheinbar nette Art aber jetzt nimmt sie
die Sache gezielt in die Hand sie
schaltet Kontaktanzeigen
Witwe mit Stadtwohnung gepflegt
alleinstehen Führerschein suche
unkomplizierten Mann steht da oder treu
sorgende Kameraden und gelernte
Krankenschwester sucht wohlhabenden Mann
der mit ihr harmonisch einen ruhigen
Lebensherbst verbringt und so geht
unserer Schwarzen Witwe im Frühjahr 1994
Friedrich Dürkheim ins Netz er ist
Rentner und 64 Jahre alt
schon nach wenigen Wochen zieht sie zu
ihm in sein Haus in Leopoldsdorf südlich
von Wien und am 16 Mai läuten die
Hochzeitsglocken also elf Tempo das ist
wirklich krass gleich nach der Heirat
lässt sie sich von Friedrich das Haus
überschreiben dann geht die übliche
Behandlung mit
am 7 August erhält er eine Überdosis und
erleidet einen Schlaganfall während
Döcker im Krankenhaus liegt verkauft
Elfriede das Haus und hat wieder
reichlich Kohle für Casinos Friedrich
Döcker kommt als schwerpflegebedürftiger
Mann aus dem Krankenhaus und lebt jetzt
in elfriedes Wiener Stadtwohnung sie ist
schlau genug und lässt sich mit dem
weiteren Vorgehen jetzt ein bisschen
Zeit
sie pflegt ihren Mann vergnügt sich im
Spielcasino und nimmt die Behandlung mit
eukon wieder auf Friedrich Döcker
verstirbt am 11 juni 1995 mit 65 Jahren
dank der intensiven Pflege durch seine
Ehefrau
[Musik]
Elfriede Blauensteiner ist jetzt auf dem
Höhepunkt ihres mörderischen Schaffens
über die vorigen Morde hat sie einen
Anwalt an der Hand der sich routiniert
und vertraulich um die Testamente ihrer
Opfer kümmert Harald Albert Schmidt ob
er auch von den Vergiftungen weiß das
ist unklar Elfriede ist mittlerweile
endgültig Meisterin in der Dosierung des
blutzuckersenkers Eugen und noch während
Sie Friedrich nach und nach aus dem
Leben drängt schaltet sie die nächste
Kontaktanzeige alleinstehend und
häuslich in Wien fürsorgliche Pflegerin
62 Jahre einen Meter 66 sucht
Weggefährten für das Alter nur ernst
gemeinte Zuschriften
es antwortet im Oktober 1995 der
77-Jährige Alois Pichler er ist nach
wenigen treffen quasi Schock verliebt in
die rotblonde Elli überschreibt ihr
schon nach Tagen seine Sparbücher bald
muss er zweimal mit Unterzuckerung ins
Krankenhaus da klärt Elfriede doch
besser schon mal das rechtliche
sie lässt pichlers Testament
verschwinden und verfasst mit Hilfe
ihres Anwalts Schmidt an neues am 20
November 1995 verabreicht Elfriede ihm
einen Cocktail aus euklukon und dem
Antidepressivum anafranil
Alois Pichler wird bewusstlos und
leistet keinen Widerstand als sie ihm
eiskalte Handtücher über Kopf und
Schultern legt und die Fenster öffnet
Alois Kreislauf wird immer langsamer die
Atemzüge immer flacher
rechtzeitig vor dem Kollaps beendet
Elfriede die Kältebehandlung und ruft
den Notarzt
Pichler stirbt im Krankenhaus wer weiß
wie lange Elfriede Blauensteiner so
weitergemacht hätte aber sie hat nicht
mit einem Neffen pichlers gerechnet denn
das Tempo der Beziehung und die
Todesumstände die haben ihn misstrauisch
gemacht
er zeigt die Witwe an und endlich wird
ermittelt endlich fällt der Krieger auf
wie viele Leichen den Weg der Schwarzen
Witwe Pflastern es kommt zur einklage
und zum Prozess die Bild-Zeitung
protokolliert den fünften
Verhandlungstag der Richter
wie war das als Alois Pichler starb die
Witwer
ich machte ihm noch ein Süppchen
plötzlich sagte er zusammen sagte hilfe
mir ist so schlecht von da an ging es
bergab mit ihm
warum haben sie keinen Arzt gerufen
ich habe mich an sein Bett gesetzt er
erzählte aus seinem Leben aber einen
Arzt wollte er nicht dann holt man gegen
seinen Willen den Doktor er war doch der
Herr im Haus aber auf einmal lief er
blau an und aus was mit dem Alois
in zwei Prozessen nämlich 1997 und 2001
wird Elfriede Blauensteiner wegen
insgesamt drei ermorde jeweils zu
lebenslange Haft verurteilt
weitere Taten wie der Mord an fatili
alias Otto Reindl oder dem Hausmeister
Niedermeier die lassen sich leider nicht
mehr nachweisen wie am Anfang zitiert
bestreitet Elfriede jede Schuld und hält
bei jeder Gelegenheit ein Kruzifix in
die Luft trotzdem landet sie schließlich
in Haft und dort stirbt sie 2003 im
Alter von 72 Jahren an den Folgen eines
Gehirntumors 13 Jahre später meldet sich
zum ersten und vielleicht letzten Mal
elfriedes Tochter Maria Wort sie gibt
dem österreichischen Fernsehen ORF ein
Interview ihr Gesicht ist gepixelt die
Stimme verfremdet wir haben sie ihre
Mutter als Kind erlebt ich war voller
Angst und ich war abhängig ich hatte nur
meine Mutter und ich war ihr völlig
ausgeliefert sie war manipulativ und
unglaublich kontrollierend
meine Kindheit war eine Gratwanderung
manchmal hatte ich das Gefühl als würde
ich knapp am Tod Vorbeigehen wenn meine
Mutter zornig war hat sie mich manchmal
halb Tod geprügelt wie hat die Art wie
ihre Mutter gemordet hat zu ihrem
Charakter gepasst das ruhigstellen das
war ihr wichtig dass er jemand völlig
ausgeliefert ist das hat dazu gepasst
sie hatte es gern wenn jemand krank war
ich glaube es war ursprünglich gar nicht
beabsichtigt dass sie jemanden umbringt
vielleicht ist das bei ihrem zweiten
Mann einfach passiert der ja angeblich
das erste Opfer war vielleicht ist sie
dadurch auf die Idee gekommen sie könnte
das absichtlich tun und damit eben Geld
erben
hat sich ihre Mutter jemals bei ihnen
entschuldigt hat sie Reue gezeigt es hat
eine Situation damals gegeben bei meiner
Einvernahme bei der Kriminalpolizei da
hat sich meine Mutter einmal dafür
entschuldigt was sie uns mit dieser
Sache angetan hat
so nah war ich meiner Mutter vorher nie
und nachher auch nie wieder
das nächste Mal habe ich sie in der
Untersuchungshaft gesehen da war das
vorbei und ab dem Moment hat sie alles
nur noch geleugnet auch mir gegenüber
was hat bei Ihnen beim Tod ihrer Mutter
überwogen Schmerz oder Erleichterung ich
hätte ursprünglich geglaubt es wäre die
Erleichterung es war dann aber doch der
Schmerz es war ein Verlustgefühl und
diese Endgültigkeit das war mir vorher
nicht so klar dass doch immer noch diese
Hoffnung da war man könnte noch
irgendetwas besser machen
und das war unser Fall für heute wir
haben ihn erzählt mit Einträgen aus der
Zeit der Wiener Zeitung vom ORF und der
Bild Aufnahme und schnitt Toni Hayer das
Skript ist von Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion wakeword München wir
hoffen ihr seid beim nächsten Mal wieder
dabei und wir freuen uns natürlich auch
wenn ihr uns eine Bewertung hinterlasst
und die Glocke aktiviert eure Toni und
euer Mirko